this morning we were remembering some of
the heroes of World War two on this day
seventy-five years ago on this day they
were making their final preparations for
the largest seaborne invasion in history
think about that for a second
CBS News reported CBS news radio rather
reported from the front lines on d-day
that network was responsible for much of
the information that was related to
Americans back home Anthony Mason is at
the Normandy American Cemetery and
Memorial good morning to you again
Anthony good morning again Gail this is
where that historic Allied invasion of
Europe began on June 6 1944 Americans
learned about the critical operation on
the radio when eyewitness accounts were
beamed to them over the airwaves it was
a turning point in history
as Adolf Hitler's German war machine
tightened its stranglehold on Europe the
fate of the continent and the outcome of
the Second World War
hinged on the success of one epic
invasion this is Bob Cobb speaking we
started this particular broadcast at 3
o'clock in the morning Eastern wartime
Allied troops began landing on the
northern coast of France this morning
strongly supported by naval and air
forces
more than 160,000 Allied troops
including 73,000 Americans would take
part in Operation Overlord on the
beaches of Normandy the American people
listened to every word that was coming
to them from CBS radio and Murrow and
his team of correspondents because
everyone had such a vested interest in
the war everyone had a loved one who was
fighting in the war CBS newsman Edward R
Moreau who broadcast from a rooftop in
London during German bombings on d-day
would read the words of encouragement
from Allied commander General Dwight d
eisenhower motion to duty and skill in
health we will accept nothing less than
full victory CBS News radio was on the
front lines of the Allied invasion that
day and inside the living room of the
American public
[Music]
[Music]
I floated on that beach which is fill
under considerable enemy gunfire CBS
News correspondent Charles Collingwood
was embedded with Allied troops along a
50-mile stretch of French coastline
[Music]
[Music]
we all in affiliate with modern war is
amount of oil and burning everything
they did was new the American people
received updates on the war live every
night that was the first time in history
that the American people had been able
to receive that type of immediacy from
credible journalists who they could
trust CBS News correspondent Richard C
hottelet who was one of those voices
aboard an American bomber witnessed the
first wave of Allied forces invading
Normandy and the Germans trying to hold
the line it took more than two months
for the Allies to break out of Normandy
following d-day liberating Paris on
August 25th and securing victory over
Germany by the spring of 1945 but d-day
came at a tremendous cost 10,000 men
were killed wounded or missing in action
including more than 6,600 Americans many
of whom are buried in the cemetery
behind McHale that's the other side of
war certainly but Anthony I keep
thinking about one of the men you talked
to who his prayer was I know someone has
to die I hope you know if it's me but if
it isn't me please let me go and not be
maimed when I go back home I still keep
thinking about what that man had to say
and what it means to you too because you
were there for the fiftieth anniversary
- in Norman oh yeah it it's you know
it's every time you come back here it's
it's just as breathtaking as the first
the skate the scale of what happened
here is just so mind-boggling it's
almost incomprehensible and and what
what those soldiers went through on that
day it's just I find it almost
unimaginable I think Thank You Anthony I
think of a journalist too who were
telling the story the picture they
painted it made me so proud to hear the
work that CBS did and really the media
back in that day to you forget all the
radio division you have to help people
visualize what was so clear so simple so
direct with chaos all around them it's
fantastic work all right Anthony again
thank you very much